[Music]
what's up everyone
we are driving from limon
on the east coast of costa rica
to san jose the capital
and el centro de costa rica
we have been checking out a lot of
properties for our regenerative
community
our building s3 s3
spirit science sanctuary science spirit
sanctuary
it's exciting stuff
we stayed on a farm
for two days one night no electricity no
nothing just
nature straight up
it was great great coffin
yup yup thanks to our friend julio boras
who is still with us
right now he's our
third amigo here in costa rica the third
leg to this bar stool
and we are currently
going into san jose to meet with julio's
cousin
and get together some of the
legalities that are necessary in order
to
move forward with our regenerative
community
building actually getting these
properties
secured because of course there are all
the nuances
in being somebody from another country
that is trying to purchase land
so it's exciting stuff keep it posted
now we'll keep you posted on the
regenerative community building of
course thanks for all your love in the
comments about the
regenerative community building and how
excited you guys are for that
we're super pumped for it as well yeah
we're building a sanctuary so
that's right that's right
what were we talking about earlier today
maybe we should bring them yeah let's do
it let's flip her around
so yeah so this is uh this is your
beautiful rica
and now what we'll do is we'll
[Music]
switch it back over
is wide angle yeah it's wide angle
all right what were you talking about
earlier today it was very interesting it
was super it was super super interesting
okay looks like we're good on uh
on the view i could just bring it a
little bit over towards tristan
like that and we should be good to go
all right looks good
[Music]
so what we want to talk about this
episode and
if julio might want to wave and say
hello
all right yes
our brother julio
it's been so so important while we've
been here
in making everything happen we're so
grateful to have a local connect
it's great that you guys yeah it's great
that you guys met and then
introduced me in as well
so what we've been talking about today
that's been a super duper duper fun
topic
is north stars
having a transcendent noble aim and
pursuing that
aka you're calling aka knowing what you
want
yes and
we'll have to be careful with the music
basically based on uh
copyright infringement oh yeah yeah we
might get
a strike for the first minute because of
the music but
okay we'll see you know we got two left
yeah yeah it won't be a it won't be a
channel strike you'll be
a copyright flag which means we can't
monetize the video
okay there's some interesting nuances to
that so even if it's only for one minute
that we play the song that the artist
can claim
um the entire 50 minutes of advertising
revenue
which doesn't really make sense if it's
49 minutes of content
without yeah yeah so i don't understand
like you you know i love making cool
videos and i'm sure other people do but
like
you can't use music it's just it's so
complicated and so just all over the
place
i mean yeah we should figure out a
better way to create
dope videos and have access to these
songs that we really like and to pay the
creators in a more
uh process driven like application or
something
i don't know anybody out there build an
app for music
copywriting for video creation yeah like
right now the way it works is that
if you have a youtube library free audio
library you can take
creators music and use that for free and
then if you use
music that's not listed there that's
copyright sensitive
like anything that belongs to the
like universal music group stuff that
then they'll flag the video and even if
you only use
one minute of the audio
and you have a 50 minute video and so 49
minutes is novel content
that doesn't use any of their music that
they'll get paid out for the whole 49
extra minutes as well and so youtube's
sort of next step potentially
algorithmically
is to maybe pay for fractional
fractional without that
that makes perfect sense yeah so we can
use
songs throughout and then pay artists
and creators that makes better sense
yeah
but then also the producer of the video
because they made something novel
still deserves a chunk of it instead of
zero well isn't that that whole like
digital
uh uh you know the nf what is it
nft can you can you kind of give a
little uh
brief about that because i've been uh
seeing hearing interesting things and uh
i would like some context on that yep
so we'll play with nfts for a bit and
then we'll
go to the north star conversation
because that one is
yeah yeah that one's the core of what we
want to talk about on the episode
so in essence a non-fungible token when
you look at something like
a bitcoin a bitcoin is something that
you and i can exchange
because the bitcoin itself does not
represent a unique
asset like a non-fungible token would be
for
a crypto kitty the crypto kitty
is a specific crypto kitty that is only
if it's a tristan tyler blake crypto
kitty it's a cryptokitty that looks like
you
that's wearing a little co-network
sweater right
and it's doing its little dance at the
disco
right with a little disco ball that's
spinning and that's one digital asset
that's that and nobody else owns it
except you you made it you own it
so you have an nft ascribed to that a
non-fungible token so it's for a
specific digital asset
and how do you turn that into something
that so for example so
let's just say i create a cool um maybe
a banner
for like an event or something right
like some cool art
um can i convert that into some sort of
currency like is it now essentially real
estate
yeah that's a good way to put it yeah in
at some point people will
decide on whether or not their assets
are worth
nfteing or not like a verb nft and
because for example with our youtube
show we don't care to non-fungible token
our content we don't want it to spread
yeah we don't need to make a little
simulation nft for each minute of our
episodes and then create some sort of a
person that wants to buy the minute 12
to minute 13 of this digital asset
that's too complicated but now if they
want to buy the nba
finals game four video
cell phone footage of you know somebody
making a dunk
that was really profoundly awesome then
then go for it that seems to make a
little bit more sense then
so customers for this would be like
national geographic sort of
like they would want to buy a picture of
some animal being photographed and
this is sort of like the protocol for
transferring digital content
is that yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah so
so that's uh that's a kind of high level
overview and again it's non-applicable
to things like
bitcoin and it's
very fungibility with things like
bitcoin versus the non-fungibility with
things like the tristan tyler blade
crypto kitty
uh and so there's sort of your tiny bit
of
difference there can you make your voice
a uh an ftt yeah can you convert your
voice so like so for example
you create a voice thing and then you
could sell it to some gps
company like is that sort of like the
mark the marketplace that's being
designed with these instruments at this
point is that kind of what we're going
to see soon yeah any unique digital
asset can be nft
but the thing is again is that to make
a nft for everything
is again something that people will have
to
decide and consider for themselves so
again for me
i don't give a living [ __ ] about nft our
youtube channel at all
uh i would rather again have it be
completely
decentralized and creative comments for
people to be able to take and repurpose
as they please
make something worth stealing like you
know copying and
replicating like yeah and even for
example i make a lot of
great digital assets and sketch and
enfigma
and i distribute those a lot of sort of
macro level
maps they're artistic distillations on
the nature of reality
and i don't tag any of those with our
handles or anything
because again i don't care about
people taking the memes and repurposing
them and spreading them around the world
and you know ultimately
ethically and morally and at a level of
consciousness
elevation on a planetary level that
people will figure out over time that
it's all the same
infinite source expressing itself and
that this whole conversation about
security and about
[Music]
privacy and about
hesitation with sharing intellectual
property
intellectual property all of that stuff
will melt away
over time but that's that's what i hope
i fundamentally don't like why are
multiple companies around the world
working on the same thing
that's just a waste of resources i'd
rather you know
uh kind of discontinue this whole like
you know for pharmaceuticals let's say
you can have a patent and stuff it's
like
you just found a formula of nature
that's
obvious you could like anybody who finds
it you're welcome to use it
or share it you know you can't really
patent a
piece of chemistry that's just piece of
nature i don't know
uh this whole ip um landscape
is overly complicated it's protecting
industries that need to evolve revolve
um yeah totally
so yeah so the north star conversation
is really
important to tristan and i because
not only in high level perception which
we published in
november last year did we really focus
on in chapter two especially on seed
theory we focused a lot on north star
perception and it was a big
overall theme throughout this analysis
of the most genius people that have ever
lived and died before us today is that
they had a
transcendent noble aim that they pursued
vigorously throughout their life
and that they dedicated their entire
soul essence to that and that then that
brought them lots of daily meaning
and purpose and fulfillment because what
they did
was go so hard towards
achieving some sort of a goal that would
maximize human potential in a way
and tristan and i have both identified
for ourselves that that has been a
mission critical component of our lives
as well as in other people we've noticed
that
when they do that that it
makes their life so much better
you know one of the interesting
conversations that i have with a buddy
of mine
um you know we have kind of a different
way of identifying meaning and purpose
and uh and
wants right what do we really want um
and you know i've always been very kind
of like
comfortable with knowing what i want and
i just go in and get it i
sort of sense oh yeah that's what i want
intuitively and it's so
and this friend of mine uh you know he
always describes that oh well that's not
that's not kind of the standard
other people don't work like that and
for me you know it's really strange to
say
what do you mean other people don't know
what they
want you know why not
and and i think this uh sort of uh uh
being conscious of the fact that other
people are very
different from you and you know that
people have different just layers of
maturity layers of kind of experiences
um and different wants different types
of wants even right
it's very interesting to try try to
recognize
that uh not everyone is like you know
everyone thinks
like you and just to keep that in in ram
i find that to be very helpful in
understanding other people sometimes
yeah some people don't want
a transcendent noble aim that they're
aware of that then
guides their life like a calling or a
north star
and when people undergo said process
what happens is a more
tangled up
[Music]
web of ideas and desires
that don't really have a direction and
they kind of get dragged around by
algorithms and scripts
and that
tangle ends up having the
whole end of life they're laying there
and as they're laying there on their
death bed there's a thought
that why when i was 20 did i
not pursue that idea why when i was 30
did i not
make that decision to travel to that
place and to learn that new thing
or to pick up that new skill why did i
have so many regrets why did i never
untangle that massive bundle of desires
and thoughts that i
never aligned to a single transcendent
noble aim that then
drove my entire life i haven't i have an
answer for this
it's fear fear and
micro hesitations which are born out of
fears
small fears are you know on on kind of
you
can't pinpoint the fear but it's there
and it
makes you hesitate just a fraction of a
second longer
and i find that this sort of um
you know the the speed at which you can
conquer a fear or reconquer it every
time
allows you to hesitate less and
therefore you know
you you can capture the opportunity
um when it's in front of you otherwise
you lose it you can't even recognize it
while it's
there and then somebody else may take it
in a competitive landscape
right you know so fears
i think is what uh makes people hesitate
and makes people look away from the
thing that they're truly passionate
about i often speak about this and and i
keep relearning it
every you know a couple of weeks that my
deepest passions
are hiding behind my fears
and i've had so many of them like i have
to keep on conquering them
and rediscovering whether it's childhood
passions so
very recently you know i got uh
re-involved in gymnastics and kind of
remembered the
feeling that i had in childhood at a
little like circus school
right like a russian jewish circus
academy thing
and i really enjoyed jumping on the
trampoline and doing backflips and stuff
and now some of the pain
in my back has gone away in some of my
kind of i've just conquered some of
those things and i've returned to this
childhood
uh passion of mine and it was it was
hiding behind
a tremendous amount of uh sort of
baggage fears that i've accumulated
in you know through from childhood
through adulthood
[Music]
yeah that was a great answer is that
you'll have these bifurcations that
occur
in your life and one of them will be
on the decision tree towards hell or
suffering
or fear or misery or anxiety or
depression
and it's usually when you don't take
that tangle of desires and thoughts
and use your will and use your choice to
untangle that towards the other option
on the branching which is towards heaven
towards flourishing towards abundance
towards prosperity
towards your own north star executing
and
not only for yourself but for your
family your friends your community the
world at large
and so to see
that by dedicating yourself towards a
transcendent calling
it makes it so that
you don't have those regrets on the
deathbed
that you end up courageously
going on these heroes journeys and that
you
end up gaining super valuable wisdoms
and treasures that you then
share with your family in the world
and it's super exciting and it's divine
and that's why it's one of the most
common
archetypes of existence is
to identify one's calling
or north star and pursue it
with intense single-minded vigor
and bring the right tool set you see
this is kind of what i learned about
launching expeditions if you don't bring
the proper supplies
you will struggle you will you will have
pain during that thing you will
feel you know unprepared you like don't
bring enough oxygen to everest or the
right shoes on the hike
and i think experience and kind of just
doing it a few times really teaches you
what gear you need to bring with you
and your utility belt or your experience
you know
essentially like module right like which
experiences can you use
to um navigate a situation or an
environment
uh successfully so also bringing the
right tool set
is critical and you know these are these
are
fun to kind of prep and prepare almost
like a bag
before you take a journey and there's
something about
being ready for the trip that i've also
identified where
you have to be prepared to go on this
journey
and what is that readiness kind of
what what do you think that sort of
state
between you know just being kind of not
ready for the trip
and having that sort of threshold passed
and now you're just
you want to go and explore
yeah great question it's like the fruit
that becomes ripe and then falls from
the tree and it falls into the hero's
journey
and as you go on to the hero's journey
you
face so many obstacles and challenges
that you still have to persevere through
and that is such a valuable
part of attaining wisdom in the process
and then becoming a mentor
to other people so you have your mentors
on your hero's journey and then you
become a mentor to other people that are
on their hero's journeys
that's beautiful yeah and
in terms of this sort of backpack that
you want to pack really
well for your hero's journey everest
climb is that naturally when the fruit's
ready
and ripe it falls and that
you're gonna go with exactly what you
need
yet at the same time to be vigilant
about what exactly you're bringing with
you
and so in this case it's things like
you want to make sure that you know how
to learn
meta learning oh yeah learning how to
learn
that's critical yeah and so tristan and
i are both
hyper obsessed with this and that's why
we make for great
friends and partners is because we know
how to
systematize learning a language we know
how to systematize learning
about biology we know how to systematize
learning spirituality we know how to
systematize
the very processes after 10
plus years of investigating them
ourselves
to where we know how to apply the power
law
distribution where you need to identify
only the
approximately five percent of aspects to
biology or to spirituality or whatever
the the keystones the keystones those
cornerstones those most
macro level understandings that give you
the greatest
amount of breadth and realizations in
the
field right off of the bat and so in
this case it's like when you go off
make sure that you know how to learn
optimally make sure that when you get
into understanding biology
that you're not jumping into
a a
single species of animal in your study
but rather learn everything about the
fundamental unit in biology which is the
cell
first learn about dna learn about
proteins
learn about rna metabolomics etc learn
about all these
components inside of the cell that then
give you the greatest
understanding of how it operates as a
neuron as an immune cell as in
across species all this type of stuff
so a person is uh so so there's kind of
a two-step process here
uh process one is there's uh just a
tabula rasa
person doesn't have a uh uh you know a
north star
a mission you know you talk to somebody
who's you know in these uh hostels that
we've been at right there's these 20 25
up to 25 year olds in there
can they actually don't know what they
want to do they're going to school
but they haven't chosen a program they
don't know what they're even interested
in
right but they have to choose a program
which which i i
actually uh i want to i would love to
challenge that paradigm like
you don't know what you want to do until
you've done enough things
and to kind of force somebody into a
degree or something is
sort of narrowing the scope uh and you
better
you hope you're lucky in choosing the
right narrow
lane to go down because uh the cost of
returning
and starting another pathway is just too
great
you know at least for the education
system that we have today and uh this
goes into the uh uh you know the
education system that
we want to create uh in order to
resolve this problem to allow people to
choose multiple simultaneous directions
kind of almost like the same way a um
what do you call those the
the algae would take the uh the
slime mold yeah you know imagine like i
don't know what i want to do but you
slime mold your
uh options and then the fastest kind of
connect the one that has the the most
food at the source or the most sort of
uh you know thing that excites you
so how would a person
identify something that they're really
passionate about
what does it feel like when you're
holding something in front of you
and i'll give you an example uh for me
i know now 34 years old
that if i'm really like if i start doing
it
and i can only last about 25 minutes
before i'm just
overwhelmed with excitement like i'm too
i'm just
too intensely excited i know that that
is a
so that would be like let's say studying
star formation
or or black holes or like you know all
these phenomena uh these interesting you
know the voids in in
in space the uh lanikai super cluster
look up lanakaya super clusters any
video on that
and my it's so intense
for me that i have to turn it off like i
have to move on to
current events news or something or like
i have to just do something familiar
because i'm so um stimulated
hyper-stimulated right super mega ultra
stimulated
that uh that i can't continue on and i
think that the process of um sort of
distributing this intense uh of emotion
and feeling
over a long period and just kind of
learning to not be
over excited by something is the process
of
learning to cope and learn this thing
so that's a meta process for me if i'm
too excited
i recognize that that's immediately a
deep passion of mine
and i need to almost desensitize
myself to the excitement of that thing i
literally become afraid of how exciting
it is
right success you become afraid of how
successful you
you know how pop the possibilities
imagine this thing
actually works out you get so
overwhelmed with excitement
that you stress that you it's hard to
sleep to a certain extent
right so yeah
desensitization through just uh
repeated um interaction with it
fifth sixth time you're already more
like you know
i've been here before it's it's not as
scary as it
simulates and that's the funny thing if
you really watch your fears
uh actually
fear can like it's not ugly it's it's
the truth you're afraid of the true
information that's actually always it
you're never afraid of [ __ ] or
something wrong or
you know fantastical you're always
afraid of the truth
and that's exactly where you need to
look in order to find
uh a what's been missed or b
step stones to the next path
the truth cannot be ugly
yeah those are that was great so we have
this sort of
slime mold analogy where we've talked
about this like a
buffet also in high level perception
over the last couple of months where you
want uh
kids to have a buffet of options
for them to be able to yeah they're
north
stars and callings for them to figure
out to grow out like the slime mold and
then
like tristan described there's a
and before we get to that point there's
a fog that sometimes happens where it
covers many of the options on the buffet
where if the parent is very dogmatic and
is very focused on just
money or something that's a good job or
a specific religion
is another way to put it if it's just
focused on dogma and fundamentalism in a
specific religion
then the child's options will be
super constrained as well and then
similarly if the parent is obsessed
in pushing their child into just
business become a lawyer or something
yeah
or lawyer doctor and so
to remove that fog over the other
options on the buffet
is mission critical and then the other
point
that we were talking about was that
there's a feeling
that comes when we've identified
the option on the buffet like the slime
mold
that is most gravitated towards that was
gratifying
gratifying towards that star towards
that calling and
and so what that what that typically
feels like
is like tristan described a little bit
ago there's a
there's a level of divine resonance that
is
unavailable anywhere else and so it's
not something like
a massive instantaneous eureka
and you're like oh my gosh this is it
for some people it is like that
but for the vast majority of people it's
kind of
like uh huh this is pretty interesting
and then it sort of grows on you over
time if you if you're playing the
piano for the first time and it's like
okay this is hard but i
really am loving just the way that i can
combine musical notes into songs and
then you keep doing it over time and you
learn your first song and then you play
it for somebody and you make them really
happy
and you're like wow that was fun and so
you kind of
learn that vibe resonates with you
and that then that becomes
the
it feels sort of that calling or that
north star position
and by the way the calling or north star
position it can be
something that is
piano might fill the position for you
know three years five years it could get
you it's a step
it could be a step to the next
instrument to the next instrument or
potentially even to
understanding uh cymatics or mathematics
or what not as sort of
the next things deliver you to other
yeah
and and by the way like today uh i don't
do something unless it's hard
i've you know reading about memory and
learning and how all that works
at this point i recognize if i if it's
something easy if it's something
familiar to me
i'm not learning i'm just autopilot
doing
uh but if i'm really struggling so i
struggle with mathematics and
uh and that's pretty that's where i'm
like oh that means i'm
actually learning that means i'm
actually covering new territory it's
sort of an indicator
yeah that wait a minute you're a new in
a new property in a new land
and there's something to discover here
that you haven't already found so
at this point you know i found a lot of
things and and
i know i've cataloged and i know what
they are and i'm looking for
new ones rather than just being in the
familiar territory so i pre i demand
my new hobbies or passions to be
difficult
because i want to learn a new skill and
and actually kind of challenge myself
simple things don't really even not
simple but but
easy things that are connected to things
i've already mastered are not
fun at this point not divertido as we
say
yep yeah you can feel that so within
this sort of
north star calling you'll have a you'll
have a zone that's typically called your
flow state
and then you'll have the zone sort of
below that which is like this shit's too
easy
and you'll have the zone above that
which is this shit's too hard
and so you really want to stay in that
flow state and so
the idea is that if you go and you jump
to the huff
vibration and you're trying to
understand
how the
quaternions work that you're probably
going to be in the too hard zone
and that you'll probably
for me i felt a similar thing as tristan
was describing where i was like holy
[ __ ] i'm
actually really hardcore learning some
stuff about math right now
and that it felt very flow state-y but
it was definitely
borderlining on the too hard and so you
almost know you're like okay well don't
push it you know it's a natural
intuitive feeling
okay well don't push further than this
into the hardcore mathematics
but ease a little bit back into the kind
of explain like on five macro level
understandings
of where the hop vibration is actually
practically explainative
in things like the way that the
helical movement of the solar system
around the
black hole in the center of the milky
way is visualized
and the way that that also is mirrored
in the as above sofa below phenomenon of
the dna double helix and so
the the too easy is usually where most
people find themselves
stable they kind of sit there and enjoy
sort of feeling
comfortable yeah so this is where you
have
the classical phenomenon of
well i could on this bifurcation
pick use will or choice
to do something that requires more of a
cognitive load
of the pursuit of my north star
which might be learning how to play a
new song on the piano
or might be picking up another lesson in
python programming
and the other option on the decision
tree
is to go out to the bar with my friends
or it's to
watch a familiar youtube video something
you already know
or even a distractive
netflix show or whatnot and so sedate a
very sedative
uh show and so
to view your north star trajectory and
your entire
calling in life as a series of
bifurcations where you're constantly
undergoing the choice or the will to
delay your gratification towards
something that's divine and transcendent
versus something that's instant
gratification oriented
it's a really profound visualization
for perpetually choosing the delayed
gratification
options so how would one go about
kind of finding this north star or
identifying it
you know is is it a feeling you get so
for example hop vibrations right uh
very interesting mathematically complex
requires a tremendous amount of
geometry you know kind of non-euclidean
geometry stuff whatever
and you know there's symmetries there
there's a bunch of words
that you don't understand and they
require
their own sort of context and when you
look into any one of these words you
don't understand that
what words are being used to explain
those concepts
now so so here's a key concept that i
would really love to deliver to
everybody in a very clear and simple
you know five-year-old language you can
learn
any phenomenon that exists
in our current reality
you know if you want to
so if there's anything you've ever
wanted to understand
whether it's how the sun works
how does biol you know how does the dna
and we talked about this earlier when we
talked about meta-learning and power
laws
yeah so you really want to go from the
most
simple fundamental units like an octave
when you're playing piano to understand
how the octave works
to understand how the fundamental unit
and biology of the cell works so a
technique for this that i wanted to
share is essentially and like everybody
should be doing this all the time
write down any any new word
that you don't know the precise meaning
of
and it could be a technical term or
it could be a uh you know an actual word
like uh
you know a beautiful word of some sort
right uh
you need to write them down and save
them and
just define them later kind of like read
about them
so you need to fill your vocabulary you
do you need to grow your lexicon you
need to grow your nomenclature
you need to grow this mental lattice
work that you have
and this is part of the school pedagogy
that we're building out
where you'll grow your own and visualize
your own unique
lattice work that will then enable you
to do things like the fire
fire and wire repeatedly
in neuroscience so that you actually
retain
the information that you're learning and
you make novel connections between those
fields and so in this case it would be
something like
only a couple of years ago did i even
learn that the word metaphysics exists
so i never even knew that there was a
word for the study of the nature of
reality
i never even knew there was a word for
that and so
again having added that to my
nomenclature to my lexicon into this
lattice work
now i'm able to more easily reference
the study of the nature of reality i'm
able to look at the more nuanced
intricacies of that so if you
take that concept and then you define it
yourself
and then you go and you read the
wikipedia about it you go and you read
the stanford philosophy documents
about it and you just repeatedly
search for all of the world's most
profound
metaphysicians that have ever lived and
died before you that's the formula yeah
and if you if you're truly feel like
you're obsessed with the study of the
nature of reality
you will come to the one the same one
end about our infinitude that
all of the others came to and it's the
same truth with biology as well
is that if you go and you study the
fundamental unit in biology
you will over and over again recognize
that dna
rna proteins metabolomics
the stem cell differentiation the animal
plant fungal human kingdom
kingdoms expressions of said
biological expressions you will
absolutely come to the same one
end if you go really hard and you can
get
it done in three years or five years
instead of 30 years
yeah and so that's that's a main core of
what we are talking about in our
pedagogy you can certainly concentrate
a lot of these ideas into understandable
packages
and really get a sense for how dna works
now the details the kind of going in
deep deep deep into the you know alleles
and the expressions and all this stuff
um you have to build that on those
kind of trails on top of um a
sort of standard database of knowledge
of
kind of a lattice work of information
um so we're
i just heard abs the word obsession
and for me that's always an if
somebody's obsessed about something
that's an indicator that they found
their north star
or their full speed ahead this is uh
you know a direct path right almost
one-way ticket
uh that's a prerequisite for
um for knowing what you want
sort of like once you know what you want
you become
obsessed in achieving it or just
obsessed about
a certain concept
is obsession uh something that
everybody experiences or is it more
likely in
some people kind of and and is it even
you know sometimes it can be destructive
in terms of an
ultra obsession right you forget to eat
and sleep because you're working on your
app and whatnot
um so let's talk a little bit about
obsession because i personally
uh well i i don't do things unless i'm
obsessed by them it's just i don't see
the
you know you you can't create anything
unless you're
you're obsessed with the object so
how do you feel about uh obsession and
uh
yeah yeah similarly with that power law
description that's so powerful
there's the vast majority of people on
the planet right now
8 billion are
sort of
beginner to amateur level obsessed about
certain things and very very few people
are hyper obsessed about their
north stars and callings and so it just
follows that power law distribution and
that
some people are also like you were
indicating obsessed about
ice cream and pizza in netflix
and other people are obsessed about
curing cancer
and so you're gonna get a
destructive obsessions
like cocaine and you're gonna get a
positive obsession like providing
a billion people that don't have access
to clean water with
it yeah yeah so and we had an awesome
conversation yesterday about
uh really you know the people that are
the most creative can
also have the same turnkey for
destruction
like it's just as easy to create
the world as it is to destroy it yeah
tristan used the example of
you can with your genius you can make
precision medicine or precision missiles
yeah
so and i personally um i struggle with
this because as an inventor
and you know somebody that plays with
technology and just experiments with new
forms
this is actually exactly where
spirituality morality ethics comes into
play
is that when you combine your science
technology
engineering which is you can either make
precision missiles or precision medicine
with spirituality morals and ethics what
happens is
is that the pendulum swings more and
more towards
precision medicine yeah away from
precision
now i am currently
uh essentially i i have a strategy to
maintain the positive
technological uh sort of spirit right
i am in this state where i'm focused on
learning about
stem cells and medicine and how to heal
the mod
the body and the mind um but when i'm
in a dark mode in the sense of maybe i'm
financially strapped or maybe
you know somebody cut me off and i'm
angry maybe kind of somebody
as you know i just feel un
uh like underappreciated right and we go
through these waves uh
whether they're real or not is
irrelevant we all feel them
and it's during the moments of your uh
sort of weakness your your fog
that you forget the the important
lessons
and you forget sort of your north star
and you just grab on to anything that's
nearby
you sort of go into this sort of fear
mode uh we were talking yesterday we
don't like to listen to our fears
because they're so
uh you know they're intense and the
amygdala wants to say something but you
have to ignore it
and use the you know the prefrontal
cortex you have to
give yourself a second to um get back
onto
clarity and stable ground so
i personally find that music
and and dancing actually
brings me to joy it's like
i have these two neuro tilts that that
communicate with each other and the
the warrior jew
only puts down his sword
or his weapon when the music man is
playing an instrument
uh and we've been talking a lot about
this kind of um
you know war dance uh
dichotomy right i see there's literally
no difference between war and dancing
capoeira fighting it's converting
you know fighting and like like impact
into art and dance
uh these tribal uh sort of the new
zealand uh the
the you know the maori and all these uh
uh different
uh tribes they dance
this it's a they literally dance with
like war
instruments but they make it into beauty
and i i personally believe
that we can convert our war lust
into profound music
and dance and that's my goal
is to remember how much i enjoy music
and to always steer towards
dancing and music and family and love
versus
conquest war destruction
i'm very open about this like uh as a
man
you know i would love to thrust the
spear into
a competitor just i i'm i hear it i i i
know myself
i would love to go to war and win to
conquer i would love to take a city i'd
love to conquer this city right here
but the question is um
imagine everybody wanted to do that
there's no room for survival our species
isn't worth
uh preserving if we're all going to be
this kind of
ape conquer sort of primitive uh
lizard thing
i think today even if you want
even if you feel the need the compulsion
to conquer and dominate
um well at this point
i like to surrender and try the other
way like i i really
you know it all learned how to lose what
does not fight
all boils down to do you know yourself
at the end of the day
it was written on the top of the temple
of apollo at delphi
2 500 years ago it's been talked about
for
millennia know thyself what does that
mean
know thyself as the ultimate know
thyself as the absolute
know thyself as the highest expressing
itself endlessly
and you are that and you are the form
and identity that you've taken on right
now
and it's exciting and it's playful but
it's a costume
and you're in a play that's on an
eternal stage
and that most people are obsessed with
their costume
and therefore they have these tendencies
or these habits as tristan has indicated
where they're like why don't i drive my
spear through the heart of somebody else
or why don't i
conquer this land why does the world
have such a tight line with war
why why why well it's because they don't
know themselves they don't know
themselves because they think that
other people are actually belong to some
sort of
other thing when it all belongs to the
same infinite source expressing itself
in that we are all that so under
the costumes is the one heart
under the costumes is the one heart and
if you don't know that
you're gonna have tendencies of
malevolence that arise
and more self-destruction or
self-destruction and when you do know
that
when you do know thyself what happens is
malevolence dissolves when you truly
know the one heart when you truly
know it it dissolves you know what else
it says on the temple of delphia
there's two other delphic maxims yeah i
i
actually the one that really resonates
with me is nothing in excess
yeah nothing in excess and the other one
is surety brings ruin
those are the three nothing in excess
for me you know because i'm very
excessive like as an obsessed
guy like if i do something i do it
intensely
uh some would say two and just all in um
and and you know it's uh like
one of the things that i've been
learning in these this funny kind of
counters
a lot of the principles of what we've
been talking about because
nothing in excess when it comes to
drinking six glasses of wine per day is
a good idea
but nothing in excess when it comes to
pursuing your divine transcendent noble
aim
is well hold on a second maybe i should
be very obsessed
about that and focused on that but i
shouldn't
go so far into obsession and excess with
my north star
to hurt myself that i forget to stretch
my body that i forget
to take just eight hours of sleep
etc yeah it is a very strong
entrepreneurship
so it's a very strong aphorism and yet
at the same time
remember that what you put into your
north star position
does deserve your absolute highest
sacrifice excessive
when you actually you know so it's it's
funny
how many when you actually achieve one
of your
goals you actually get what you wanted
sometimes you know and
it's we're at 52 so let's round
[Music]
it's very interesting when you actually
get what you wanted
quite a while ago and then you're like
ah
like this isn't exactly like i don't i i
got it but i don't want it anymore or
it's not really what i expected and
having gotten exactly what i wanted
a few times now
and getting another chance to you know
i'm so grateful for
multiple chances to get what i want and
then to try again to not be forced to
stay
with the thing that you wanted the first
time right actually the world
as it is now is currently a uh an old
wish that i wish i could take back
the things that are happening now
geopolitically and stuff
um that was a wish from another decade
and and i'm so kind of disappointed
in my um just lack of uh sensitivity to
the consequences of my
wishes you know so i don't blame this
whole thing on me but
um i wish this into being uh
and now i want to take it back and that
goes into
uh knowing like before you
go and get what you want like once
you've identified something you want
make sure you really want it
like have a way to establish if it's
something you actually want
because when you get it do the five whys
okay why why why why why so
when you list your north star and your
north star
is i want a house then you ask
why no and then you go because i want
shelter
and then you go why because i want
[Music]
to feel safe and then you go why because
i feel unsafe and then you go why
because
well i don't know why i feel unsafe
maybe it's because of something that
happened in my childhood or whatever it
is
and so the five y activity is good and
then if you sort of
perpetually structure the five whys
more and more towards something that
actually
is a transcendent noble name that's not
something that's just
material so there's a big difference
between your calling
or your north star being a a house or a
sports car versus when it's
a giving the billion people on the
planet that don't have access to clean
water clean water
or solving one of the greatest energy
challenges of
nuclear fusion etc fusion physics yeah
plasma physics yeah
so over and over again ask yourself
these why questions
and get down in the deepest roots
of why you want what you want to purify
where you're coming from
so that it's coming from a place of
solving one of the biggest
challenges that maybe you locally or the
world faces
any scale of that that resonates with
you but then where you're coming from
in terms of are you doing it purely for
service to yourself and your family or
are you doing it
in the world or are you doing it from a
place of trying to
extract a house or a sports car or
whatever
out of the equation so that you can
feel secure feel something that you feel
is currently lacking
yeah uh yeah that's working on the
underlying thing you know it's
interesting like
oftentimes you speak to people and they
want things that they already have
and they don't know it like they already
have you know some some people will say
like oh i need to i need to make a
million dollars so i could go
traveling and it's like um why don't you
just go traveling now
and there's no reason why they can't uh
other than this
condition that they've set in order to
artificially um distance themselves from
the uh activity or the or the
required kind of acts you know oh i'll
do this
once once we move to a new place and
this is
basically sometimes people put uh sort
of
blockers in front of their goals that
are artificial
and have nothing to do with actually
achieving uh what they want
so it's quite interesting to watch
people uh oftentimes have something that
they
think that they want well so summary
is north star slash calling slash
transcendent noble aim hone in on that
as deeply as you can repetitively
untangle yourself from the mixed bag of
frequencies thoughts feelings desires
compulsions
emotions behaviors patterns that
don't give you a clear daily
meaning and purpose and something that
you can contribute to yourself as a deep
responsibility to your family
to the world at large so untangle those
mixed frequencies towards
a calling noble aim nor star
that is divine and perpetually
hone in on that on a daily basis and
you'll
as is said in the sanskrit tradition
karma yoga you surrender the fruits
don't pursue the fruits purify where
you're coming from so that your north
star has nothing to do with
you obtaining some sort of material
possession
but rather through your perpetual
service
you will inevitably gain
from that process as well which is
mission critical
yeah kind of yeah i really like that a
lot
um you know don't be extractive kind of
be uh uh in the sense uh
giving and and sort of shepherding
yeah that was a great discussion i
really enjoyed that good one um
we love you guys love you tristan that
was great bro
yeah that was great show them a little
bit of the yeah
all right so uh let's write in your what
you
want into the discussion thing like uh
because the most exciting thing about
figuring out what you want is actually
meeting others that want the same thing
and accelerating that process
kind of getting there faster together
which is why we're building s3
s3 right yeah it's a so finding your
community
um becomes a lot easier once you can
accurately
um verbalize the thing that you're
searching for
and just ask anybody you know the other
people that are in the same
uh sort of that know that vocabulary and
right away you have some
something in common that you can work
towards which is really fun yup so
leverage the simulation community
let us know how you feel about the
episode in the comments below
with your north star with your callings
share those in the comments see if you
guys want to send each other some direct
messages
and collaborate and create together we
do also have our sim club
option as well by joining the channel
you can check that out
and also if you video brought you value
give it a like subscribe if you haven't
share the video with other people
that you feel like this would resonate
with and we
adore you very much love you love you
infinitely thank you
for tuning in and this will probably be
the
last pod that we do we have a lot of
sort of legal stuff that we have to take
care of in order to make this
regenerative community happened before
we both leave costa rica and then come
back to continue
architecting so adore you stay tuned for
that
and we're pumped to share that with you
as well all right
much love bye-bye